welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Voss and nick fury's introduction to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe scene in the
Iron Man post-credit scene nearly set
the stage for this universe to be even
more expansive according to a recently
revealed alternate post-credits scene by
Marvel head Kevin Feige this deleted
scene with just a few simple alternate
words gives us a pretty uncanny insight
under Feige stinking cap into his vision
for the future of this cinematic
universe perhaps even where it's going
in the next few years now as a reminder
here's how the scene played out in the
normal version Tony Stark returns to its
Malibu mansion to find an intruder you
think you're the only superhero in the
world mr. stark you become part of a
bigger universe you just don't know it
yet for the hell are you Nick Fury
director of shield I'm here to talk to
you about the Avenger initiative and
it's talita bursts in fury added last
time I lost a minus tag now at the
Saturn Awards Kevin Feige revealed a
never-before-seen alternate version of
this moment and which fury uses some
different language bikes and assorted
mutants weren't enough I have to deal
with a spoiled brat who doesn't play
well with others and wants to keep all
his toys to himself
Marilyn Nick Fury director of shield I'm
here to talk to you about the Avenger
initiative Oh what are we avenging
whatever the hell we want
so in this deleted post-credit scene
fury is alluding to three big Marvel
heroes The Hulk spider-man in the x-men
gamma accidents obviously refers to
Bruce Banner whose film would be coming
out a month after Iron Man came out in
feature its own post-credits scene with
Tony Stark sitting down with Thunderbolt
Ross radioactive bug bites obviously
refers to spider-man and it's crazy that
as early as 2007 when the scene was
likely written in shot Mikey already
intended on spider-man being part of his
Marvel Cinematic Universe someday and
think about it this would be right after
the third Sam Raimi Tobey Maguire
spider-man came out and years before the
Marc Webb Andrew Garfield spider-man
reboots
but this was also a couple years before
Disney bought Marvel Studios before that
Marvel was more flexible with its studio
partners they partnered with Paramount
to distribute Iron Man and with the
universal to distribute the Incredible
Hulk
so what wasn't out of the question to
assume that
might partner with Sony to co-produce a
rebooted spider-man something that they
eventually did in 2015 a deal that sadly
now appears to be over
or at least for now until Disney stocks
up everything and this might also
explain the third Marvel group that fury
mentioned the assorted mutants referring
of course to the x-men now in 2007 the
Hulk spider-man the x-men were by far
the most popular and most recognizable
Marvel properties even more so than Thor
Captain America or the Avengers is a
unit with Nick Fury hinting at assorted
mutant Spidey was similarly shooting the
moon suggesting that mutants had already
existed in his MCU and that maybe Marvel
Studios could partner with box where
Feige worked at before becoming head of
Marvel to co-produce an MCU x-men now
this move would have come shortly after
x-men The Last Stand so imagine in May
2008 after the two biggest Marvel
superhero franchises on film with less
beloved downbeat finales enters Nick
Fury with a promise of the coolest reset
ever now of course this version scene
was replaced with a version that we saw
perhaps because marvel's deal with
disney was coming which would complicate
any future collaborations with rival
Studios like Sony or Fox and Phi geek
didn't want to make promises that he
couldn't keep yet but I think it's also
worth noting that Fury referred to the
x-men as mutants like similarly at
comic-con last summer
Feige hinted that quote mutants were in
development not x-men so it appears that
from the beginning
Feige has insisted on referring to the
x-men in a more general term mutants
suggesting he might intend to
reintroduce them outside of the lens of
a Charles Xavier crew one that he
recruits and trains and organizes into a
commando response team not all mutants
are x-men some are in the mutant
Brotherhood some are just kids wandering
around a world so this might give us a
sense of Feige state of mind when it
comes to characters like Wolverine what
if it's not about the x-men which if you
remember that line in Dark Phoenix
pointed out it's kind of a narrowly
tailored term anyway these days what if
it's more about existing in society as a
mutant and other an outsider Charles
Xavier and his school for gifted
youngsters is nowhere in sight we could
just tell the stories of these genetic
freaks how cast it from society trying
to fit into a world where the only other
advanced persons they know about our
experiments gone awry like the Hulk
cap one a Maxima vision rocket or rich
or well-connected dudes with cool suits
Tony Stark James Rhodes came to chala
Peter Parker and now mutants would have
to find a way
to carve their own place in this society
but I mentioned Tony Stark's technology
I think that technology might be the
other clue for how Kevin Feige sees
Marvel moving forward and pays for
because he notice in this deleted scene
fury call stark a brat who was to keep
all his toys to himself and I reminds us
that Tony Stark's arc throughout all of
these films was a transition from
selfishness to selflessness it's been a
story about a genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist learning to share
Avengers endgame brings Tony to full
selflessness Tony returns from
retirement to share quantum technologies
so the other Avengers can navigate time
travel in the quantum realm something he
does after being inspired by an old
photo of Peter Parker and after making
the ultimate sacrifice play
he shares his kingdom of toys with Peter
Parker as we saw in spider-man far from
home that battle over Starks legacy and
his technology remains a key conflict in
years to come and while the drama with
Sony might close off some of those story
arcs when it comes to spider-man and
like Mysterio in the MCU I have been
speculating that the resurrection of the
10 rings in the upcoming shang-chi film
might indicate a threat to others stark
tech like say a gauntlet and suit that
stark built to contain cosmic godmode
jewelry like the Infinity stones but
also like the 10 rings so that might
mean
Tony's toys aren't yet being done played
with and now based on this deleted
post-credits scene we know Nick Fury saw
this threat come in over a decade in
advance so what do you think Kevin Feige
secret plans are for the mutants and
Tony Stark's tech in phase 4 comment
down below with your thoughts follow me
on instagram and twitter at EA vas and
subscribe to new rockstars to breakdown
some theories of everything Marvel thank
you for joining me I'm Erik Voss and
last time I trusted someone I got locked
in a blue dungeon